I just want to start with is there
anything that you geek out over like
maybe it's cameras or I'm not sure about
is there something that you geek out
about
um you mean in general in life yeah like
is there anything you collect what do
you geek out over I am I geek out of
over uh my uh machine shop
I am
I have I have a CNC machine late a lot
of metal working uh things we build a
lot of stuff you know here in the garage
I love it honestly that's awesome uh if
you anyway
um so you have done such incredible work
over in your career
um but there's going to be people who
have never seen anything so if someone
has never seen anything you've done
what's the first thing you'd like them
watching and why
um I I I I think I think I think
obviously it's always the last film you
know
the film
um the last film you've done it it's
it's it's always sort of a cumulation of
things you dropped and things you added
and uh
and um you know you're constantly
growing you're constantly evolving
you're constantly you know
becoming wiser slash more stupid more uh
interesting slash uh more stuck up
but I think you know
um
you always like to show the people who
you are at the moment so so so I kind of
I kind of uh I kind of feel the last
film is always the the nicest one to
watch uh what would surprise Christopher
Nolan fans to learn about making a movie
with Christopher Nolan
um I think I think what what what what
surprises or surprised me and and and
and what was something that I I had to
learn with you know from working with
Chris is that he is a
extremely intuitive person as well you
know
he's he's of course known for his you
um you know mind-bending intelligence
and you know his films they always feel
extremely well put together and
extremely
well planned but but what what is very
beautiful with Chris is that he is
somebody that
um is not afraid of you know following
his heart and and and and
um you know reacting to
you know intuitive impulses as well
you know he's a very he's a very
sensitive and and and and and and very
much a feeling person you know it's in
that way
um I also feel that helped him very much
in communicating with actors you know a
lot of actors there are also people that
work extremely much on on sort of an
intuition level you know and ultimately
with a film you're also sort of
translating a feeling to the audience
you know and it's uh and in that way
that was something that uh that
surprises surprised me back then because
it doesn't surprise me today anymore but
but um as people call him sometimes oh
he's very technical
um you know I would definitely debate
that he is one of the most sort of
sensitive and most intuitive directors I
I I I work with so one of the things I'm
fascinated by are the the various
processes that people make movies for
example Ridley Scott will shoot with six
cameras and or seven cameras and Roger
deakins will shoot with just one and
that's it so I'm curious how often are
you just using one camera on set and how
often do you like to do coverage well I
mean I mean for most of the time we work
with one camera on set you know
uh effectively uh
you know shooting with Chris is like a
one camera show it's it's it's it's it's
a camera is sort of the sort of the
magic uh box that has to you know
everything that that happens around has
to uh you know be directed and and
evolving towards you know getting sucked
into that one little box you know so so
so so so so that one camera really
becomes an epicenter on our on our on
our shoots as soon as you put two
cameras on the set you know that that
attention gets somehow divided and and
and and be with Christmas that is
extremely focused focused group of
people that really work to towards a
very specific goal
and you know Chris is also somebody that
um loves to loves to uh uh you know sit
very close to the camera you know in
order to understand what the camera is
seeing so so he's always very close by
uh looking into the Set uh next to the
camera you know he's not he's not a sort
of a a material collector or a cleaning
lady or a vacuum cleaner you know he he
it's it's in that way it's very
meticulous and very focused process you
know the actors know exactly towards
where they're working uh the production
designers you know the the prop people
the set dressers uh but also you know us
lighting Etc it all it all has to evolve
towards that One Direction and and and
and and so
one camera shoot just feels very logic
to us you know it's it's it's sort of a
very Ultimate Way of filmmaking for us
it feels very focused so you shot with
IMAX film and you also shot with a 65
millimeter and I'm curious how can you
talk about the conversations you guys
had as to when it would be an iMac shot
versus not an iMac shot well I mean uh
as I said before you know
um
as a lot of it is very much pulled out
we also we also work a little bit with
our intuition there and that intuition
is also very much led by
the idea that we just want to shoot as
much as possible on as you know as rich
as possible negative so we uh we love
shooting as much as possible on IMAX and
also in this film you know the more
intimate the the the the the situation
got you know the more sort of up close
and personal uh things called the more
you want to get in there with an IMX
camera now of course the IMX camera has
a few technical limitations that make it
very hard and very challenging you know
it's a very loud camera and it's it's
also bulky and it's big so
so it's not obviously you know something
you cannot be a fly on the wall for
instance uh with it so so so some
situations as much as you want to they
sort of require you to rethink it a
little bit and and something we had to
record dialogue so we would
we would shoot on the five per 70
millimeter camera
but we very often would add an extra
shot
or an extra take on an IMAX camera
you know to see if Chris could
probably Salvage the sound of it and and
put it in a film so so so so so
um
ultimately it's I would say it's a very
intuitive choice but it has a
very uh an intuitive Choice uh but but
driven by sort of the will to squeeze as
much as principle in there listen I I am
so thankful about what you and uh uh
Chris do with IMAX it's my favorite
format there's nothing like sitting in a
theater in that huge iMac screen
um what do you actually love and hate
about IMAX cameras like if you could fix
something in an IMAX the big camera uh
besides the set like is it just the
sound of the how loud it is
if if if we would be able to fix the
sound you know I'm a camera it would be
fantastic right uh now uh it's almost
like to to to solve that sound problem
is is like defined physics you know it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's not just
asking I'm here can you make this thing
more quiet you know what you have to
imagine and and if you just hold on one
second I'll just grab something so I can
show you sure we got some real fun
things here some film strips
so no no no no now let's start with this
one
right I'm just gonna show this this is
35 millimeter right
can you see it I should go against the
wall this is I I can see it
this is 35 millimeter anamorphic
that size
so a camera in in order to to get these
these 24 shots per second in the cam
has to drag 24 of those frames per
second through a camera correct
so now
we go five Perth which is a camera that
is
70 millimeter that
um
does the same as a 35 millimeter camera
and why are these cameras so bulky and
heavy this is five perfect old-fashioned
65 millimeter camera
so per second 24 of these big frames
have to be pulled
through a little little hole
well it gets a little louder it gets a
little bulkier but if you look at IMAX
yeah about a second
this is how your negative Expo is
exposed and this is how the film strip
looks
hold on a second
no that's instead of going like this
through the camera it goes like this
through the camera and here you see
every frame is a huge piece of exposed
film so 24 of those frames you have to
pull through the camera per second
so you can imagine how much power and
inertia and how big motors you need in
order to do that and how aggressive your
mechanism has to be to every time stop
that frame on the dime
so so that's the reason that that camera
is so loud and it's so bulky and it's so
heavy it's just physically it's very
heavy and it's very very very difficult
so there there you have the problem I
would love it to be as silent as a as a
as a as a nothing but
um it's uh it's very challenging to get
it there but that's definitely some
improvement that I would work on and the
more quieter that camera becomes
the more situations we can start
applying that camera to so so so
ultimately quieter would be my wish I
don't care so much about it making it
smaller
you know making it more comfortable you
know we're all the time sort of adapting
the ergonomics of that camera you know
but and in the end
um you know it's a little box it's a
mini mini fridge they can put in a
special place and
with grips that have the sensitivity of
ballerinas and a little bit of smart
external engineering you can get the
camera wherever you need it to be but I
think that that sounds that's something
that that would be really wonderful to
uh to to do something with this is going
to sound crazy and I'm obviously just
brainstorming in the moment but is it
possible to actually make the camera
bigger for certain situations and like
almost blanket the camera with like
soundproofing so instead of going
smaller you're you're going larger and
you're minimizing all the sound coming
out of it and you're using it in
specific shots where you don't have
camera movement or it's on a device that
can move it's not crazy at all I mean
that's exactly what we we have built a
certain device like that blimps they're
called so we have blimps for the IMAX
cameras you know
um
coffin we sometimes say but it's it's
literally a device that fits like a
glove around or or like a like a sort of
comment that fits like a glove around
the camera
and it's made out of different
soundproofing materials and yes you get
it you get it quieter but but here by by
those kind of experimentations we
already found out that exponentially you
have to get so big
just because the sound in relation is so
loud you know and also what you have to
think about a lot of the sounds
that comes out of that camera comes
through the Lens comes through the front
of the camera oh yes and and and you can
you you know at some point you cannot
just keep layering uh your Optics you
know it's uh it's uh because that will
in the end start to really affect your
uh your some your your picture quality
well all I can say is you just
demonstrated it with the examples of
film but the fact when you capture an
image on an IMAX frame like that you're
capturing so much more information
that's one of the reasons why even when
you film on IMAX I don't think people
realize when you film on IMAX and then
you bring it down to even 35 millimeter
the image is still so much better
there's so much more information there
oh yeah absolutely I mean a trickle-down
effect that people underestimate very
often very much but it's uh it's you
know it if you if you if you if you
trickle down from an original that is
pristine and that is great you will feel
feel that quality trick people down very
very much in the in the in the the you
know derived uh derived formats every
time you
you you print down or you you you you go
down a resolution you lose you lose a
lot of
um you lose a lot of detail and you also
gain a lot of artifacts and the the the
the better your original materials the
Lesser archifects you get so so so I I I
I when I look at that and you know at
Apple you know or whatever
and I I look at something that's
originated in in in 70 mil or something
that that this originated in 35 mil I
can very easily Spot the Difference yeah
I spoke to Chris and he told me there
are no CGI shots in the movie which I
found amazing
um but what was it like when you and him
and everybody involved were talking
about filming like certain sequences
especially the use of light and he wants
to use these big IMAX cameras and do
everything in camera can you sort of
talk about you know working making
everything happen with the visual
effects team obviously well I mean I
it's for me is always super exciting uh
period in in in in the prep you know
that it's like you know everybody is
sort of throwing those crazy ideas into
the hats
and a lot of them they don't have
necessarily Technical Solutions to it
then you know step by step you know
people come up with all these kind of
weird Solutions and weird ideas
that we then you know very often test
and we start testing them as well as we
start building them like it was very
clear to us that we wanted to like like
very early in the start that we wanted
to you know and I'm talking then about
Andrew Jackson and Scott Fisher you know
our glorious
um you know
additional and special effects team that
were very working very close together
also because facial effects and special
effects on a
a shoot like this is very closely
related because you know Andrew Jackson
as much as he's connected to a visual
effects department wants to rely as
little as possible on CGI so he really
took control over trying to get as much
as possible in in camera as well in his
in his sort of little you know world
and with the help of Scott Fisher so
they they work very close together but I
um I I am uh you know
as much as we wanted this to be IMX and
part of the IMAX sort of sequences
um we realized that we want to shoot a
lot of micro or macro photography on
IMAX you know a format that doesn't
really have those kind of possibilities
right so we straight away we we we
started engineering those uh that's
those specific lenses for the
for the IMAX camera effectively you know
when you do this sort of micro
photography you know when you want to
have a camera for instance in between
here or track in between here to to to
to to to enlarge the world of this to a
sort of a a life-size format you you
need special lenses you need this this
what we call probe lenses
they didn't exist for IMAX so so that's
the sock from Panavision build us this
this this probe lens and we've
experimented with it and we improved it
and and in the end it was something that
we used a lot for aquarium work and
micro work and micro work so that was
that was very exciting
um you know and and and and basically
the visual effects Department you could
say was was was was was a tent that was
always put up next door set where
we're doing all these science
experiments you know we would like you
know shoot molded metal shoot into
aquariums with silver particles or you
know do micro explosions of balloons in
Reverse etc etc there's a lot of a lot
of like small little very tactile
physics experiments going on that we
don't try to
try to film in in different ways and um
and with different kinds of cameras as
well and
and and then sort of Cobble together you
know this this kind of idea of you know
the the
um you know quantum physics or particle
physics or you know atoms crashing into
each other or
um a gigantic nuclear explosion etc etc
cool thank you so much for your time and
seriously I really I really love your
work thank you thank you